this award tonight would have humbly
validated Heath's quiet determination
to be truly accepted by you all here
his peers
within an industry he so loved thank you
Heath was such a compassionate and
general
who added so much excitement and
adoration to our lives we have been
truly overwhelmed by the honor and
respect being bestowed upon him with
this award
tonight we are choosing to celebrate and
be happy for what he has achieved
Heath we both knew what you had created
in the Joker was
extraordinarily special and had even
talked about being here on this very day
we really wish you were but we proudly
accept this award on behalf of your
beautiful Matilda